(カエル)はじめ･･･
（カエル）はじめんはハロウィン嫌いなのかい？
(はじめ)うん。
(カエル)そっか･･･
(はじめ)昔ハロウィンの日に、東京に行って、人が多すぎて、まったく動けなくなってその日帰れなくて、すげー嫌な思いをしたんだ。
(カエル)そうなんだね･･･
(はじめ)こんにちははじめしゃちょーです･･･
バン！バン！バン！バン！(机をたたく音)
お待たせしました！
ﾜｯｼｮｲ!
もう18回目なんだね･･･(困惑)
今回も15万件以上のコメントをいただきました。本当にいつもありがとうございます。
今回特徴的だったのは･･･
まあ強いて言うとちょっと意味不明なコメントが異常～に多かったです。
なかなか面白いコメントが多かったんですけども、
今回もその中から選んで選んで選び抜いたコメントに答えて行こうと思います！
では行こう！
あぁん？(半ギレ)
あぁん？(マジギレ)
裁縫針じゃねえわ！
ありがと。
アスパラガスじゃねえわ！･･･ありがと。
最近この食べものに例えるパターンめちゃくちゃ多いん気がするんですけど。
おい素麺･･･
素麺じゃねえわ！
人参じゃねえわ！･･･元気だよ。
小筆じゃねえわ！･･･ありがとっ！
エビせんじゃねえわ！
ありがと。
長芋じゃねえわ！
俺が悪いみたいになってる・・・？
チンピラじゃねえわ(笑)すごいコメントだなぁもう･･･
牛どんじゃねえわ！もうディスかどうかも分からんわぁ！
靴紐じゃねえわ！
落ち着きます。
死なねえよバカ野郎(笑)
なんかガチっぽくない！？
ﾌﾞｯwwwwwww
完全に嫌われてますよ。
コナンくん。
わぁ！あぁありがとうございます！
間違えんなや！
生き物というのは生きた瞬間いつか死ぬので、死ぬのは僕は仕方ないと思っています。
僕も死ぬのは怖いですけど、
まぁ、いつ死んでもいいように、いつもしたいことをして、暴れてます。
皆さんもぜひ、後悔のないように、後悔のない、毎日を過ごしてください。
ピングさん。
(歯の音)
へぁ！
へぁ～！
へあっ！
へぁ！
うわああああああ！
(チ～ン)
(口笛)
うわぁ～！
(チ～ン)
なんか君たちすごいコンビネーションがいいね。
そりゃもちろんだいす･･･
誰ぇ？
なるほど、これは面白いな･･･
1回やって見ましょうか。
え～マジでコレ俺やっちゃうよ？
つぶやいて見ます。
はい。
あ～やべえつぶやいちゃったつぶやいちゃった！
やばいもう反動がすごい汗かいちゃう///
おおお～やばいやばい
すげえ反応してくれる人と、もうなんか「え～」みたいな感じの人が、たくさんおる。
やっぱこういう感じに、されちゃうんですよね･･･（顎
大丈夫か？
(ここ、大丈夫？)
嫌いと言うか、ちょっと気にくわねえなみたいな奴らはいますよ。
割と(はじめの闇)
(ピー音)
そんないないな。
ん･･･なんか本当にこいつら好きでやってるのかな～みたいな奴らは好きじゃないっすね。
そうだなぁ･･･人生で一番つらかった･･･
全部言うんじゃねえ！
ジャイアン！
あんまりいつも言えないから言うけどさぁ！
いつも応援してくれる人！
本当に！ありがとぉぉぉああああ！
あっ！あっ！あ！
正直ね、ディズニー貸切はありっすよ！
なんか機会があったら、やろうと思うんで
みんなで･･･ディズニー貸し切ろうぜ！
割とその･･･アイコン好きだよ。
僕もコンビニでバイトリーダーみたいことやってたんですけど、やっぱり叱れないんすよね怖くて。
（先輩）いらっしゃいませ～
（後輩）いらっしゃいませ･･･あぁーっ！
（後輩）先輩！先輩！すいません･･･お皿･･･
（先輩）わあああああああ！
2!3!5!7!11!13!17!19!
怖いよ･･･
ケンカする気しかないじゃん･･･
なんだろうな･･･やっぱりしっかりとした女性はきゅんときますなぁ･･･
しっかりとした人に、こう、「はじめくん･･･//」みたいな感じで甘えられたりしたらもう･･･
な～に言ってんだ俺！
一番憧れている人は･･･
実はルパン三世です。
あぁ～恋をしたのは～♫
ザクッ(たまねぎを食べる音)
あ。
あっ意外と･･･うわあああああ
息抜きする時間すらもったいなくてずっと勉強してたんですけど
勉強中に、ホワイトミルクチョコをずっと食べてましたね。
いやほんと甘い物を食うとね、心が幸せになるんで。
うわあっ！
そっち！？
(ピー音)
嘘だよありがとね。
怪しすぎる！
彼女がいるのに迷惑じゃない･･･怪しいにおいがする･･･
今すぐにでも･･･
手をひけー！
とりあえず寝よう。
ふぅ～！
はぁ！
ふわぁ！
ふぇぇ！
ｳｳｳｯ･･･ｳｯ!（吐く）
それなァ！？
あああああああ！
ふうううううう！
ああああああ！
ふわああああああ！
ふわああああああ！ふわ！ふわ！ふわ！
(はじめの悲鳴)
あああああああああ！
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ♪
ﾍﾟ･ﾍﾟ･ﾍﾟ･ﾍﾟﾝ☆
うわああああ！
ﾎﾝﾂﾁﾞｭ、まって、まって、まって･･･
笑いじゃないほど痛い。
ちょっとまって…イッテェ
はい、みなさんコメントありがとうございました。
質問コーナー怖いよ･･･
もう痛いのやめようね！
いやもうほんと皆さん･･･ﾊｧ・・・痛い！ﾊｧ･･･ありがとうございました･･･ﾊｧ・・・
痛い！･･･痛いよ･･･バイバイ